[Musique]
bernard edwards bonjour bonjour à vous
est ainsi qu à tous les auditeurs et
auditrices demande les premières
président du medef martinique
associations patronales partenaires des
institutions pour discuter par exemple
du développement économique de la
relance du climat social d'un haridwar
il ya cette nouvelle équipe à l'elysée
une nouvelle équipe à matignon depuis à
peine quinze jours et on y est déjà dans
le dur cette réforme sur le code du
travail les discussions commencent enfin
il était temps
mais on peut dire qu'il était temps
puisque la campagne présidentielle a
quand même occupé le terrain pendant
beaucoup de dents c'est bien le cas de
le dire fait chaud quoi le président
mâcon utilité et lui il y avait un point
fondamental transformer l'économie
française pour feront j'ai un nouveau
modèle de croissance pour le faire il
faut investir pour accompagner cette
transformation dépenser moins peau des
hommes d'une organisation administrative
plus efficace et conçu des régulations
économiques pour la zone euro med a fait
la campagne du d'emmanuel maquereau à la
campagne de mac os mais je rappelle sa
campagne
les mobiles de sa campagne près pour
réussir tout ça il a mis l'entreprise au
coeur de sa campagne
donc il est évident pour que
l'entreprise puisse fonctionner il faut
des réformes
oui il faut des réformes et je crois que
le président du medef a été reçu par le
président cette semaine en début de
semaine et il a rappelé les principales
axes de réforme il faut être sacrifiés
d'abord il faut simplifier également les
licenciements parce que le code du
travail c'est trop gros le code du
travail c'est 3000 pages je crois qu'il
faudra grande et en simplicité
particulier à ce code du travail et
traiter des problèmes de pas quitté de
temps de travail avec un sorte minimum
vous savez ce que dit jean luc mélenchon
qui était candidat candidat de la france
est soumise c'est que si ce code du
travail est très gros c'est parce que
c'est paris une véritable bible des
luttes sociales que chaque page marque
l'avancée des luttes sociales
écoutez je laisse monsieur mélenchon
libre de ses propos je pense que c'est
pas là la proche du medef il faut savoir
qu'en des les 3000 pages du code du
travail
il ya quand même tous les lois et les
décrets d'application de tout ce que le
son du travail beaucoup dérogation
demandée par le medef chaque fois
quelque chose qui arrive sur la tête il
faut qu'ils soient consignés
part mais je pense qu'on peut faire plus
simple aujourd'hui par rapport aux 3000
pages que comporte ce code du travail la
réforme du code du travail c'est aussi
des dispositions sur une formation de
qualité alors lorsqu'on parle de
formation lorsqu'on parle de formation
de qualité ici en martinique nous émeut
trouver injurieux mais ça fait presque
rire sourire parce que ça ne fonctionne
pas ça fonctionne mal parce que ça
fonctionne pas comme on le souhaite il
faut semble l'idef le souhaite sa comme
le medef je crois comme tout le monde ne
veut puisque je compte travailler sur
une réforme ambitieuse de l'enseignement
professionnel et de la formation est une
réforme qui font qu'il faut appliquer je
vais vous donner une statistique en
martinique
nous collectons plus de 15 millions
d'euros destinés à la formation sur le
plan national et nous ne récupérons que
5 millions d'euros la faute à qui c'est
la faute au système si on peut dire mais
il ya moyen il faut comme indiqué ge des
toits zone et aider verrouiller toutes
ses implications et applications qui ne
sont plus d'actualité 15 millions de
côté et combien rappelé l'autre chiffres
et récupère 5 millions donc il ya de
quoi faire et cette semaine en début de
semaine avec cette exaspération que tout
le monde ressent aujourd'hui cette idée
que rien n'avance c'est pas un peu du
foutage de gueule de dire il ya quinze
ans de récolter 5 millions qui sont
servis mais il faut lier des
statistiques
tant qu'on ne les a pas on peut pas
valablement continuer à réformer ou et
il faut pas avoir peur et comme le
président du medef l'a dit il faut avoir
de l'audace
aujourd'hui de dire les choses comme
elles sont et engager les réformes qui
sont nécessaires dans l'art et douars il
y aura le troisième tour de la
présidentielle là des élections
législatives
des députés par exemple sur cette
formation professionnelle ils auront un
rôle à jouer vous allez leur demander
quoi au plus de 50 députés actuellement
en lice est ce qu'ils ont conscience de
par exemple de ce petit veau la
formation professionnelle qu'on peut
qu'on devrait nettement améliorer
j'ai tenté de dire cinquante candidats
passés comme député ces quatre candidats
dont je crois qu'il faut il faut
distinguer deux choses il faut
distinguer le rôle des parlementaires
d'accord et le rôle des collectivités ou
de la collectivité territoriale
ces deux aspects totalement différent
donc c'est sûr que si on veut réformer
il faut que nous parlons à nos députés
et nous allons les rencontrer mais si on
veut faire avancer l'activité économique
dans notre environnement
il faut interpeller la collective on va
revenir de l'activité mais les députés
quand même parce que manuel baroin est
élu président en mai ce sont les députés
qui feront la loi ce sont des députés
qui ont la main pour intervenir sur des
champs comme par exemple le
développement économique est-ce que vous
avez l'impression lorsque vous écoutez
si 53 54 candidats en lice que c'est
quelque chose qui leur parlent vraiment
se développer que d'écouter ma réponse 4
est clair il faut laisser la démocratie
faire son boulot d'attaquant donc on
choisit et puis ensuite on discutera
avec et puis après on se rencontre sauf
qu'on choisit en fonction de ce que les
uns et les autres disent non mais c'est
sûr mais yens volonté politique derrière
c'est sûr que nous allons rencontrer les
députés qui seront qui sont les
candidats qui sont en liste de façon à
faire valoir ce que nous souhaitons paul
mattick notamment dans thème de
l'entreprise et de l'emploi
alors bernard edwards la population
quand même cette désagréable impression
que cette martinique notre martinique
chéri notre pays stable que ces élus ne
font pas bouger les lignes
alors quel message aujourd'hui quel
message ah ben il faudra qu'on passe à
un autre message il faut faire bouger
les lignes il faut avoir de l'audace la
martinique en a besoin et la martinique
la douane valls et qui doit impulser
cela ben c'est à la fois le monde
économique et le monde politique et je
crois comme l'avait dit le président
marie jeanne quand je les rencontre et
ya trois semaines il faut que le monde
politique aille vers le monde économique
et il faut que le monde économique aille
vers le monde politiquement il est
président du medef depuis novembre 2016
on se rappelle des votre élection que
vous aviez dit que la martinique
pourrait avancer à condition que que la
collectivité de martinique bouge
qu'elles se prennent un petit peu plus
en main qu'elle soit plus volontaire est
ce que vous avez l'impression que les
choses ont avancé
ça fait quand même près d'une quinzaine
de mois que la nouvelle équipe est en
place que les choses est avancé se
serait pas normal ou le lieu pour moi de
le dire mais je pense que les choses
devront bouger jusqu'à en période
électorale ça va c'est selon vous à mon
sens ça bouge pas assez et je vous
donnais trois exemples la construction
de logements à la martinique s'est
effondré 22% de moins par rapport entre
2011 et 2015
quelle est la préconisation du medef il
faut lancer un programme de
réhabilitation de miso donc pas pacifié
il faut que jaka mais c'est un constat
ces concerts le fait depuis des années
le medef ne peut pas quémander sans dire
quoi faire ouais après il ya la volonté
politique
oui en tout cas hughton la commande
pluies qui ont atteint un de ses plus
bas niveaux chute du vent de la vente de
6 mo dégradation du secteur du btp
quelle est la préconisation du medef
lancé un programme de réhabilitation
également la de tous les lycées et
collèges
voilà voilà des idées des données qui
pourront entamer tout de suite nous
relance de l'activité économique et la
martinique et le tourisme par exemple et
les propositions alors le touriste doit
être au coeur au coeur des débats
et là nous avons justement et on va le
proposer à nos ados parlement à nos
parlementaires seront prochainement élu
nous proposons au niveau du medef une
zone franche expérimental à
l'exportation il faut savoir qu'un
touriste qui vient la martinique
dépenses entre 300 et 360 euros par jour
la nuitée d'hôtel compris la location de
voitures les deux jeunes et les dîners
les achats personnels
la zone franche économique à
l'exportation ça voudrait dire que les
achats du touriste qui séjournent choses
soient exonérées de la fiscalité
voilà une solution permettant de
relancer maîtrise mal
mais le touriste viendrait si ce
territoire est attractif tout comme par
exemple tous ces jeunes qui partent
faire des études et qui n'ont pas
franchement envie de revenir ici parce
qu'il ya un manque d'attractivité parce
que les conditions économiques par
exemple
c'est ce que la seule connexion internet
ça fonctionne pas mais là justement vous
êtes en train de faire la situation
oui le constat vaut par exemple mais des
vous dit quoi à ce niveau là il faut
voir le problème de manière beaucoup
plus là arrêtons de regarder les choses
de façon beaucoup plus large aussi une
énorme depuis son jeune âge
quand je dis plus large reste sur la
politique des activités oui nous avons
en martinique une baisse de la
population
effrayante et la conscience collective
n'a pas encore mis en garde cette épée
de damoclès lamartine qui a perdu plus
de douze mille habitants entre 2000 la
population du saint esprit la population
du saint-esprit paris s'est passé le mot
du saint-esprit et je crois que là il y
avait urgence à mettre en choses à
mettre en place des situations où des
données pour inverser la tendance
quelles sont-elles ces 6 comment peut-on
arrêter effectivement ramener un peu
plus d'attractivité à la martinique
mais prendre en main la population
scolarisée
dès la seconde puisque en fait c'est à
partir de la seconde et les deux années
qui sont après premier terminal que le
jeune prévoit de savoir sur quel secteur
d'activité va s'engager pour faire ses
études soient restés en métropole ou
dans l'hexagone dagon ou à venir à la
martinique maire s'est créé beaucoup de
jeunes qui portaient la troisième
lorsque des parents qui ont les moyens
ils savent que s'ils sont là bas ils ont
plus de chances pour réussir
possible mais je crois qu'il faut que
nous puissions le mot n'est peut-être
pas approprié mais jouer le dire von
l'attractivité de la menthe nique aux
jeunes dès la classe de seconde et le
medef souhaite peut-être pas cette année
mais l'année prochaine puisque ça
demande une organisation beaucoup plus
importante met en place qu'on avait ce
qu'on va appeler le cursus medef academy
apprendre aux jeunes ce que c'est
l'entreprise
comment fonctionne une entreprise et
comment peut-on arriver à lancer et à
vendre l'économie de l'entreprise il
manque une culture économique la marque
une culture économique elle est unique
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos
bernard edwards on rappelle que vous
êtes président du medef martinique merci
bonne journée
merci à vous bonne journée
[Musique]